[Musica]
block chain catena di blocchi
quanti di voi avete sentito parlare di
block chain in ogni modo sui giornali
internet e quanti di voi potreste dire
che cosa sia esattamente di glock chain
in poche parole è quello che cercherò di
fare in questo poco tempo la mia storia
non inizia con codice di programmazione
ma con una mano di poker
immaginate di giocare a poker con
persone che non conoscete e di far parte
di un gioco in cui nessuno a denaro
contante né fish e che sul tavolo
a parte le carte non ci sia null'altro
oltre che fogli di carta bianca
certo potreste ritagliare i fogli di
carta in piccoli cerchi e farne delle
fiches ma non fidandovi il uno degli
altri
avete paura che possono imbrogliare ad
esempio ritagliando di nascosto le
fiches o passando sele sotto il tavolo
decidete allora di distribuire queste
pagine
ad ognuno e vi impegniate ciascuno a
scrivere chi scommette quanto chi vince
e chi perde
ognuno tiene la propria copia accanto a
sé visibile a tutti
in questo modo se qualcuno commette un
errore o prova imbrogliare o anche se un
paio di giocatori provano a conludere
per far perdere qualcuno in particolare
la discrepanza diventa evidente a tutti
dopo un paio di mani avrete riempito una
pagina con un registro di scambi di
denaro
chiamiamo queste pagine blocchi di
transazioni dopo un'ora
avrete probabilmente diverse pagine e
avrete cominciato numerarle chiamiamo
questo cli coordinato di pagine catena
di blocchi di transazioni avete creato
una block chain
la prima e più importante
implementazione di block chain di cui
sicuramente avrete sentito parlare
si chiama bitcoin nel 2008 proprio
mentre l'industria finanziaria
statunitense non solo entrava in una
profonda crisi una persona o un
collettivo sotto lo pseudonimo di
satoshi nakamoto pubblica un saggio in
cui illustra una tecnologia che per la
prima volta consente di trasferire
valore digitale senza bisogno di
intermediari fidati e questo atto
apparentemente semplice innesca una
scintilla che causa stupore paura e
interesse un po dappertutto ma facciamo
un passo indietro e torniamo al poker
bitcoin è un software che funziona
esattamente come un enorme tavolo di
poker in cui milioni di persone che non
si conoscono e non si fidano l'uno
dell'altro tengono aggiornata una catena
di blocchi tante pagine con la storia di
tutte le transazioni alcune scambiano
effettivamente denaro ma molti sono solo
dei volontari che mettono a disposizione
la propria capacità di calcolo con i
computer per verificare e tenere
sincronizzata questa storia di
transazioni
avere milioni di persone che tengono
sincronizzata separatamente questa
storia può sembrare un buon modo per
garantire la sicurezza e l'integrità
della stessa in realtà in un sistema
completamente decentralizzato come
bitcoin in cui non c'è un'autorità
centrale come ad esempio una banca a
monitorare le transazioni e ad evitare
frodi si pongono alcuni problemi ad
esempio chi ci garantisce che solo il
legittimo proprietario dei fondi possa
effettivamente inviarli e chi ci
garantisce che lo possa fare una volta
sola
il protocollo di bitcoin offre garanzie
matematica questi problemi grazie alla
crittografia
ed è per questo che essendo basato sulla
crittografia bitcoin è anche chiamata la
prima cripto valuta in particolare
grazie alle firme digitali
il protocollo di bitcoin assicura che le
transazioni provengano solo dal proprio
dal legittimo proprietario
e grazie ad altri accorgimenti basati
sulla crittografia questo grande
protocollo questo grande registro
contabile distribuito del valore è
resistente a compromissioni e hacking
negli ultimi decenni abbiamo quasi dato
per scontato avere accesso al cosiddetto
internet dell'informazione se vi invio
un file una mail non vi sto mandando
l'originale ma sto creando una coppia e
non c'è alcun problema è la democrazia
dell'informazione ma per quanto riguarda
proprietà come ad esempio case azioni
denaro appunto inviare una copia è un
grande problema si rimando mille euro
è importante che io poi quei mille euro
non li abbia più e non li possa spendere
nuovamente come detto il protocollo di
piccoli risolve questi problemi che è
noto da tempo in crittografia e in la
scienza dell'informazione come il
problema della doppia spesa grazie alla
crittografia e per la prima volta
realizza il concetto di scarsità di un
bene digitale infatti esiste un limite
numero di bitcoin che saranno in
circolazione e la curva dell'inflazione
e scritta immutabile nel protocollo al
giorno d'oggi la nostra economia si basa
su alcuni intermediari e fidati a cui
deleghiamo funzioni fondamentali ad
esempio banche assicurazioni e notai
funzionano bene ma pongono alcuni
problemi innanzitutto sono centralizzati
possono essere hackerati e dunque
compromessi sentiamo ogni settimana
notizie in merito
l'ultima ad esempio la compromissione di
equifax escludono miliardi di persone
dall'economia globale rallentano i
processi ci vogliono secondi per inviare
una mail dall'altro capo del mondo
mentre ci possono volere sette giorni a
inviare un bonifico in alcune zone e
infine impongono alti costi di
transazione per inviare denaro contante
in alcune zone dell'africa le
commissioni possono superare il 20 per
cento
e se assieme parallelamente all'internet
dell'informazione avessimo un internet
del valore un grande registro contabile
distribuito un mezzo naturale di
trasmissione del valore digitale questa
grande sfida è quella che si pone la
tecnologia che chiamiamo block chain
bitcoin è una la più importante ma una
glock chain ne esistono tante altre e
tir hume è una block chain scritta da un
ragazzo russo canadese di nome vitalic
but are in all'età di soli 19 anni e la
sua caratteristica più straordinaria è
la possibilità di stipulare contratti
intelligenti smart con jobs sono dei
veri e propri contratti in codice di
programmazione che vengono eseguiti in
modo distribuito senza nessun
intermediario come ad esempio notaio
autori e si occupano di gestione
adempimento esecuzione pagamento in
maniera completamente integrata e ad
oggi sulla blog chain di etereo ci sono
dei progetti che spaziano dalla
sostituzione di borse e mercati azionari
al crowd funding start up a giochi
d'azzardo con garanzia crittografica di
correttezza addirittura nuovi modelli di
democrazia che superino le ideologie del
ventesimo secolo e rendano i politici
veramente responsabile nei confronti dei
cittadini
don tapscott qui a ted si chiede come
possiamo risolvere il problema della
disuguaglianza possiamo creare nuovi
approcci a questo problema finora
l'approccio principale è stato
ridistribuire la ricchezza attraverso le
tasse ad esempio ma se potessimo
cambiare il modo in cui si genera la
ricchezza democratizzando la includendo
più persone in questo processo e
assicurandoci che ognuno riceva il
proprio il giusto compenso secondo
hernando de soto il grande economista al
latino americano il primo problema
il primo ostacolo alla mobilità
economica in sudamerica e la mancanza di
titoli di proprietà affidabili in zone
dove l'accesso al conto bancario è molto
rara non poter dimostrare di possedere
una terra vuol dire non poterla mettere
a garanzia di un prestito e quindi non
poter fare progetti per il futuro
in honduras dove il problema è
particolarmente sentito il governo sta
collaborando con una società texana che
si occupa di block chain per mettere i
registri di proprietà su questa
tecnologia in questo modo sono
distribuiti sono resistenti a
compromissioni sono pubblicamente
verificabili seguire questo esempio
potrebbe potenzialmente creare
prosperità per miliardi di persone
si stima che più di due terzi dei
proprietari terrieri al mondo non abbia
un pieno titolo di proprietà
il maggior flusso di denaro da paesi
sviluppati a paesi in via di sviluppo
sono le rimesse degli emigrati e la
diaspora globale persone che lasciano il
proprio paese di origine
la propria famiglia e vanno a lavorare
in altri paesi ogni mese mandano a casa
nel proprio paese di origine parte del
loro stipendio
si tratta di un mercato di più di 600
miliardi di dollari all'anno e sta
crescendo una domestica filippina che
vive negli stati uniti e vuole mandare
soldi a sua madre nelle filippine con
western union deve pagare quasi il 10
per cento di commissioni e il processo
dura 47 giorni esiste un'applicazione
basato su blog c'è in chiamata a bra che
consente di mandare attraverso bitcoin
fondi in maniera istantanea alla madre
appare una notifica tua figlia che ha
mandato 10 mila pesos lei non deve
conoscere bitcoin a una mappa simile a
quella di huber in cui ci sono tanti
omini che si spostano proprio un po come
i taxi di huber seleziona quello più
vicino o quello che al feedback più alto
e queste persone per una piccola
commissione sono disposte a fare da
corriere di contanti per conto di abra
in questo modo ne seleziona 1 bussa alla
porta e riceve i suoi 10 mila pesos in
pochi minuti
il processo è stato quasi istantaneo e
le costato solo il 2 per cento di
commissioni che sono rimaste
nell'economia locale
credo che seguire questo esempio
creerebbe prosperità per altri miliardi
di persone
la grande maggioranza di autori e
creativi non ricevono il giusto compenso
perché il sistema di proprietà
intellettuale è inefficace
prendiamo esempio la musica agli artisti
rimangono solo le briciole alla fine
della catena alimentare
imogen heap grande cantautrice
vincitrice di due grammy ha deciso di
spostare la sua musica su un sistema
basato su block chaining di nome mai
silia
si tratta di un contratto intelligente
intelligente che integra un sistema di
pagamento e definisce i termini della
proprietà intellettuale
ad esempio se si vuole solo ascoltare la
canzone è gratis o costa una frazione di
centesimo se la si vuole usare come
suoneria è diverso se la si vuole usare
come colonna sonora di un film
ovviamente ancora diverso e siccome
integra anche i pagamenti questo sistema
i soldi rimangono nelle mani degli
artisti se vengono eliminati diversi
intermediari e questo non si applica
solo la musica ma si applica
potenzialmente ad ogni creatore di
contenuto video invenzioni eccetera
la tecnologia di block chain benché
nella sua infanzia si configura come una
grande e concreta opportunità di
riscrivere la rete di scambi economici
risolvendo alcune delle questioni
globali più importanti e difficili ci
consente di scambiare denaro e beni
fisici e digitali in modi nuovi potrebbe
rendere obsoleti alcune istituzioni a
cui deleghiamo funzioni fondamentali
della nostra società come banche
assicurazioni e notai costringendole a
diventare più decentralizzate e più
sicure potrebbe rivelarsi un formidabile
strumento di democratizzazione delle
risorse della ricchezza la sua natura
trasparente potrebbe aiutare a risolvere
problemi millenari come la corruzione
consentendo ad esempio ai cittadini di
verificare il flusso di fondi pubblici
potrebbe rivoluzionare il mondo del no
profit consentendo di donare a progetti
verificabili pubblicamente
e tutto questo un po in silenzio sta già
accadendo grazie
[Applauso]